we would hang out and like knot out and
stuff on the couch and then I would go
in the kitchen and pee in a bucket no I
swear so I'm peeing in the bucket also
at this point we're like just a mess so
we like use a syringe and throw it on
the ground and all a sudden we're like
wake up my she winds up waking me she
goes get up get up and I look and I can
feel the heat on my face and the couch
is on fire holy [__] the candle had
burnt down to the bottom and set the
couch on fire and I'm like oh why we
haven't I mean is it just cuz were on
drugs that were putting candles on the
edge of the couch in the first [__]
place that's what you said and there was
no like nice like we didn't even smart
enough to put it on like a plate or
something we got to be able to see what
we're doing and stuff and I'm like
panicking I'm like I got to put it out
so I run over and grab the bucket of
piss and
throw dude you put a fire out the bucket
of
P the Honeydew with Ryan sickler